- Welcome back everybody.
(audience cheering)
I'm here with Joshua
Jackson and Christine Ko.
(audience cheering)
All right,
so my next guest is a "Top Chef" winner
and one of the most respected
chefs on the planet Earth.
Her "Nat Geo" show is called
"Restaurants at the End of the World."
It's streaming now on "Disney Plus".
- [Rolando] Find your
next step before you move.
(dramatic music)
- Holy (beep).
- [Rolando] Don't look up.
Yeah, keep going, keep going.
(Kristen screams)
(dramatic music)
(audience cheers)
- Wow. Please welcome Chef
Kristen Kish, everybody.
(audience cheering)
Meet Joshua.
- Hi.
- Hi, how are you?
- Meet Christine.
- Very well.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- So would y'all ever
climb down a waterfall?
I would.
- Yes, I have.
- [Kelly] You have?
- I have, yeah.
- Wait, I, I learned a fun fact.
You also had a show on National
Geographic, is that correct?
- I did a special on National Geographic.
- [Kristen] Okay.
- But it was all under the water.
- [Kristen] Got it.
So I am now taking your
place above, and then
we can come together.
- Well,
I'll trade with you.
That looked really nice to me.
- [Kristen] Yeah.
- Underwater is cool too.
- Underwater was very cool, yeah.
- Would you ever climb down a waterfall?
- No.
(all laugh)
I wanted to lie, and I was like,
I'm not going to do that.
I'll swim at the bottom.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And like, wave to y'all.
- I would totally climb,
I just think it'd be fun.
Okay, tell us about your
new show, it looks awesome.
- So, I mean, the title
would imply restaurants
at the end of the world.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I am a chef, so we're
gathering those things
and bringing them together.
But the thing that I
love most about this show
is being able to live
how someone else's live.
How, how they live.
Because, I was adopted
when I was four months old.
I was raised in Michigan,
and the idea, and like this,
- [Audience Member] Woo!
- Yay!
- Michigan, give it up for Michigan.
(everyone applauds)
- This idea of, the
fact that I was chosen,
and that I could have landed up anywhere,
living with any family,
anywhere across the world.
And this idea always fueled
the curiosity for my travel.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it's,
it is an exercise in human empathy.
It's an exercise in education
in food, location, culture,
and just walking the path
that someone else walks every single day
and trying to learn as
much as you can about it.
(audience cheering)
- (indistinct) That's amazing.
So what are we doing today?
- [Kristen] All right, so.
- It looks like a game.
- Yeah it is a game, I've heard,
and I've watched several,
- What?
- several clips that you love a game,
and you are very competitive.
- What?
So I figured I'd give you all a little bit
of a taste of some ingredients.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Of some things and dishes
from these four places,
Brazil, Norway, Maine, and Panama.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And a little game that
I, slash your producers,
have named Traveling Taste Test.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- Okay, so how do we play?
How do we play?
- All right, so the rules are very simple.
- Okay.
- You have 30 seconds.
- 30 seconds to un-cloche these items.
Under each cloche is a dish.
Now, each dish contains an ingredient
(whooshing sound effects)
from one of these four places.
So, you have 30 seconds
to try all the dishes
and correctly place a location
card in front of each plate
that you think that dish is representing.
- Okay, and once again,
you called this a what?
- A cloche.
(Joshua laughing)
- Sure, totally.
- Yes, yeah.
- [Kelly] I was like, what?
- [Kristen] A cover.
- A cloche, I shall use
this to sound fancy.
- [Joshua] (indistinct) when you.
- Yeah, cloche, you can un-cloche that.
- We're going to un-cloche
in front of the audience.
- I like it.
- Okay, undress all your plates.
- Hey, the more you know, I like learning.
(audience laughs)
- So.
All right, so competitions are no fun
unless someone wins something
and two people lose.
- Oh, yeah.
- So two of you will lose, by the way.
- I'm sorry.
- I'm so sorry.
- I'm so sorry for your loss.
- And each,
each one of you is gonna play
for a section of the audience.
So, Kelly, we're gonna
give you this section here.
(audience cheering)
- What's up, what's up?
- Joshua you got the middle,
and Christine, you got the-
- [Christine] I got the (indistinct).
(audience cheering)
All right, so there is a huge
prize, it's a huge prize.
- Okay.
- And I'm gonna say something
absolutely ridiculous
and it's like silly, but
it's a, it is a pun, so.
- I love it.
- Please play like ninjas.
(Kelly laughs)
Shall we?
Hint, hint, there's a great cooking brand.
- I got it, I got it.
- It's a ninja prize.
- I got it.
- So, 30 seconds on the clock.
- Okay, okay.
- Are you ready?
- Yes.
- Set, taste.
- Okay.
(cloches clink)
(air horn sound)
(pensive music)
Go, go, go, go, go.
(pensive music continues)
- [Kelly] Shoot, uh.
- [Kristen] You got 30
seconds, you gotta eat faster.
- Wait, I can't.
- [Kristen] You're not even eating!
- [Joshua] I know what that is.
(audience cheering)
- Did you eat it?
- Mm hmm.
- Can I try?
- I ate that.
That one was really good.
(audience cheering)
- 30 seconds.
(pensive music continues)
You didn't even taste it.
- How 'bout this?
I don't even know what to do with it.
- How are you doing?
30 seconds, go, go, go.
- [Audience] Four, three, two, one.
(air horn sound)
- I feel like I'm wrong,
- Uh, okay.
- I'm wrong, I'm wrong, I'm
wrong, I know I'm wrong.
- I feel sorry for if,
- I panicked!
- anyone got the lobster wrong,
but I'll pray for you
tonight if that's the case.
- Okay.
- All right, so let's
start with you, Kelly.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- Mmm.
- I, ah, oh.
- All right, we're gonna come back to you
because we need to spend
some time unpacking.
- This saddest, the saddest,
saddest display, I got one.
- Oh, okay.
Close.
- Damn.
- [Christine] Oh, no.
- You got these two flipped,
so you have two points, okay.
(audience applauds)
- [Christine] No.
- Oh, no.
- I had it right originally,
and then I switched it last minute.
- [Kristen] Okay, so you
also have two points.
- [Christine] Yes.
(audience applauds)
- Wait, do we have to do a taste off?
- Yeah.
- But I'm, we might have
to do a little, yeah.
(whooshing sound effects)
- [Christine] Yeah, do, okay.
- [Kelly] So, I have one point.
- But, listen, but, Kelly,
I will say if there is any,
if there's any dish to get right,
it's certainly the lobster one because,
- [Kelly] See, thank you.
- if you did not get that right,
I have deep concerns for you.
- Yeah, would've been really sad.
- So, a tie between the two of you.
- Uh huh.
- Yep.
- I don't have a tiebreaker.
- Okay.
- But I feel like,
- Well I can, can I,
- You can have two winners,
but we still have one loser.
- here's the thing, thanks
for pointing it out.
(all laugh)
Thanks for pointing it out, Kristen.
So, I don't care that
I lost, it's my show.
My name is up there.
(all laugh)
All right, so everybody in
the audience is going home
with the Ninja Double Oven.
(audience cheering)
You'll be cooking like Top Chefs
with the power of two ovens,
in the counter space of just one.
One stove, two separate
ovens can cook two meals
in two different ways to
eliminate back to back cooking.
Thank you so much, Ninja.
Y'all, be sure to catch Chef
Kristen Kish's new show,
"Restaurants at the End of the World,"
streaming on Disney Plus right now.